let's suppose an actor has a very
emotional scene
and maybe they're running behind on set
and it's
incredibly excruciating for the actor to
be in the moment to prepare
to then perform it and then they yell
cut and then great let's try it again
is that something that's advisable or
give the actor more time to regroup you
know you talk about a difficult scene
and and
in terms of of preserving the actors
sanity and preserving
the actors energy for the whole scene so
you tell this is a very highly emotional
scene
and when he said time is running out and
things like that so there are
other there are external pressures
besides just the scene weather's bad
all these different weather's bad and
the producers looking at his watch
pretty much one of the worst things you
want to see um
there were two things and this gets into
a little bit of a technical stuff here
you say okay you would do a take and
then you say cut
and then you say okay give the actor a
moment to regroup
sometimes that moment to regroup will be
the
worst thing you could do at that moment
sometimes the worst thing depends on the
scene i'm just
going on a hypothetical scene here many
times if it's
say it's a scene and it's very painful
and there's a lot of screaming and
yelling and
whatever is going on emotionally with
the actors sometimes the best thing to
do is what
i do when i'm shooting uh which i call
looping which has nothing to do with adr
looping it has to be looping while we're
shooting is
the camera doesn't stop we finish this
scene i go again
and we depending on what it takes to set
up if they've been camera moves and all
that might take a while to get back to
the first position but let's say there's
no camera move let's say it's a close-up
and they finish i say again and just go
again and do it again
and do it again many times i will if
there's a portion of that scene which is
a let's say there's a short speech in
that event i may isolate that speech as
a pickup
and have him do that speech and do it
again now what's happening while he does
it again and again two things will
happen
i will talk to him or have the other
actor talk to him off camera
and i can tell you how that works which
is i'll tell you a
moment i can have the actor off camera
not giving him the lines from the script
except as a cue the character off camera
is throwing subtext at him
okay to actually help stimulate whatever
is going on inside
the actor i may be talking to him off
camera
okay and he will go through it again
maybe three four times that
maybe that's one that one paragraph that
one scene that one moment
what happens is the actor goes deeper
and because you were not
stopping he will go deeper and deeper
and deeper into the scene every time he
stops his the actor part of him will
will have a tendency pull him out pull
him out of that scene i want him to go
deeper into it
okay now this is the type of thing i
wouldn't throw at an actor first time
you know when the sun's going down so
this is what we're going to do
these are kind of things i do in
rehearsal when i'm rehearsing when they
actually i show them how we
may have to do this at some time so they
they're prepared for it
they're prepared for that process but
that again is another way of getting
them totally out of the actor's head
and they're totally into the character
everything they're hearing is
about the character they're hearing
subtext from another character which is
can be
devastating they're hearing me
interrogate the character which can be
different and i'll just send them deeper
and deeper and deeper in
but i'll always be there to pull them
out at the end
and we can go very fast before the sun
goes down